means that nearly a third of the uk
population
has got that full protection from
two doses of the vaccine and it's
particularly
important on the eve of further
unlocking that will happen
tomorrow especially at a time when a
concerning new indian variant is taking
hold
in parts of the country and to that end
the government has said they see this
situation as a race
between the vaccination program and
the virus and they are further
accelerating
the rollout of the vaccines we know that
the second jabs will be brought forward
for some people from 12 weeks
to eight weeks we also know that in the
next few days
over 35s will also be invited
to get the first dose of their vaccine
and it's an important effort to even
further accelerate
the coverage and immunization that the
vaccine program gives because while it's
a formidable defense there are still
gaps
in that defense and one of them is in
vaccine hesitancy
we've heard from the health secretary
matt hancock who spoke
to sophie ridge this morning and said
that out of the people
who were hospitalized with the indian
variant in bolton a few of them were
eligible for the vaccines
but they decided not to take them up so
because of that there are teams on the
ground they're now going door to door
speaking to people trying to
encourage them to take up the vaccine
the government has said it's a race
between the virus and the vaccination
program
and they are really trying to encourage
take up and they're really hoping that
as we
continue to reopen the vaccination
program can
pick up from the work that the lockdowns
and the social distancing has done
so far to continue to drive the numbers
of the virus down as we further reopen
the economy